all right guys
bang bang super excited tom is here uh
what's going on man thank you so much
for doing this
yeah it's great good to be on here
absolutely um all right so everyone
obviously knows that you
are a uh author of billy dog whale let's
talk a little bit about kind of your
background before you wrote the book
uh where'd you grow up and kind of what
did you do before you wrote that book
well i grew up in in the uk but i came
to asia
as a young as a young guy basically
after high school for a year to
indonesia
um i then i studied in the uk got my
college degree and then i
came straight back out to asia i've
spent i've been here for sort of 25
years almost now
so my made my career out here um
in southeast asia in india uh india and
pakistan did pakistan for a while
but now i'm based in hong kong so yeah
i've sort of cut my ties
with the old country and what was the
kind of the original allure
to uh to go to asia in general kind of
what brought you there and then why stay
i think as a kid i'd read you know i'd
read marco polo
and i'd seen like the film the killing
fields which i don't know if you guys
know
it's a big film in america but it's
about cambodia
um and so i was i had this sort of dream
to be a journalist from very very young
because of those kind of things you know
apocalypse now films like that um by the
time i got here
um which was the mid 90s it was more it
was more like
the end it was a big massive economic
boom and so it was very attractive as
well because it was the fastest growing
place in the world southeast asia at
that time
which very few people remember now um
countries like indonesia were booming
and so i was
attracted to sort of that fast changing
uh lifestyle that was happening at that
time in those places and then the asian
crash happened in the late 90s huge
economic crash and that's when that's
when i moved out here permanently around
that time got it and so
do you remember the first time that you
kind of heard of 1mdb
or joe lowe and kind of like what was
the first interaction you had with this
story
so yeah so obviously there's a big gap
between moving out here in the 90s and
then and then one mtv 1mdb
that story sort of started around well
the fraud started around 2009.
um but they kept it under cover for many
years
so this was a you know just to quickly
recap for your listeners this was a
an amazing fraud where a young 28 year
old at the time a guy called jolo
persuades a malaysian prime minister to
let him set up a fund
um and they borrowed billions of dollars
with the help of goldman sachs
and then they steal they just steal all
the money and
um like they steal we think between six
and seven billion dollars something like
that
um so the story first came out in 2015
when uh
a woman called claire recastle brown at
the sarawak report which is a
like a muck-breaking website uh focused
on malaysia
and a newspaper in malaysia called the
edge got hold of an email server
from a sort of disgruntled employee
who'd been involved with one of the
companies
that was involved in the fraud which we
can get into later about how all this
happened
um and those email servers sort of laid
out some of the
ways in which jola had stolen some of
his early money
um and that was really the first time
that people were
realized what a huge fraud was going on
here but it was only like a very c
it only those emails only painted a tiny
shot a tiny light onto a tiny part of
this fraud which you know
then took years to investigate got it
and i think the interesting
part uh when i read the book was this
wasn't like
a stranger met the prime minister of
malaysia next thing you know there's
billions of dollars flowing in his
pocket right there was kind of some
some thais mutual friends maybe talk a
little bit about the relationship that
joe lowe who
is a wharton grad but still relatively
young in his 20s
how does he end up building the rapport
with um you know
what is one of the world leaders uh and
and kind of setting all this up
well joella was kind of lucky so he went
to wharton in the us he went to he went
to
uh eaton and the uk or harrow sorry i
should say
and what he was able to do was meet the
kids he was from a fairly well-to-do
family himself a
malaysian business family chinese
malaysians but he was able to meet all
these extremely powerful
the kids of extremely powerful families
including the kid of
the the child of of najib who would
become malaysia's prime minister
what jolo does is he goes to what he
does he gets a
an economics degree or a business degree
instead of
um going and getting a job at wall
street or or
you know as a standard sort of
consulting job he just tries to broker
deals between
the middle easterners that he's met the
families of rich middle easterners and
then
uh najib brazil back in malaysia like
bringing middle eastern money into
malaysia
and he's a brilliant networker and back
then this is like 2005 2006 he's able to
bring in
you know hundreds of millions of dollars
of middle eastern money to get involved
in
in infrastructure projects in malaysia
um so when najib
becomes the prime minister in 2009
2008 2009 um jolo is is his sort of
right-hand man and he's only this 28
year old guy with no
who's never really held down a proper
job and he persuades the prime minister
to set up this fund called 1mdb and this
is after the the great financial crisis
in the us and
in the europe there's a lot of money
looking to invest
in in asia at that time and they set up
this fund they raised billions of
dollars
and it's the fund is supposed to improve
the lives of malaysians by
you know creating jobs but what it
really does is it doesn't actually do
anything
really i mean they just steal the money
and use it and we should go on to talk
about what they use it to do which is
which is really incredible for sure and
to me the part that i think is
interesting here is
joe lowe kind of understands what i'd
call the basics of how to commit this
fraud right the the
whole idea of like how do i set up a
shell company
in the caribbean to look very very
similar to a middle eastern funds name
but
obviously it's not and so he kind of
socially engineers to some degree
whether you know intentionally or just
by accident um
a lot of trust in the system and and
billions and billions of dollars that
you mentioned kind of flow to him
um any kind of idea in terms of like was
that something where people were
literally just ignorant and kind of
uh you know almost just being dumb and
overlooking it or was there some
intentionality there where people kind
of knew what was going on but they
didn't care because they were benefiting
in some way and the money was still
flowing
that's a great question so for example
he steals
i mentioned goldman sachs helped the
fund raise this these
billions of dollars worth of bonds so
this isn't money that the fund had they
went out and raised it
then they were supposed to send that
money some of that money to a
a partner in the middle east called ipic
which is another big
investment fund in the uh uae the united
arab emirates
but what they do as you just mentioned
is they set up a lookalike company that
looks like ipic um
but it's in the in the bvi it's a
british virgin island shell company
now of course you couldn't do that
without the connivance of the person who
was really running
ipic which was a guy called kalimhal
kabasi so it's insanely corrupt you've
got
on the malaysian side you've got the
prime minister who's involved in this
right so you have the cover on the
malaysian side jolo's running it running
this fund and on the other side on the
arrow on the arab side you have
karima kabasi who's running a
multi-billion dollar fund huge fund
um he didn't invested in uh you know
richard branson's virgin galactic and
those kind of things was a proper
company
um and and everyone knows it's going to
the fake
eye pick not the real ipic um but
but the share i guess the boards of
those companies don't know
um and then the other question is well
how how was all how were all these
billions of dollars able to flow
um when international banks that did the
transactions were supposed to catch it
too
because of course if you do a dollar
transaction the us banks are supposed to
catch it right
um correspondence banks like wells fargo
which were involved or
you know goldman itself um and what
billion dollar well shows is that every
step of the way
they did not nobody caught this stuff
and your question was it willful was it
you know everyone was making a lot of
money and so
maybe some sometimes it was people had
the wall pulled over their eyes but at
others it was willful
ignorance to make cash and make bonuses
yeah
and the part to me if i understand
correctly is the billions of dollars
that were raised by goldman for the
bonds they made about 600 million
dollars in fees which is
uh comparably kind of pretty outrageous
fee structure and so it was almost like
uh hey we're making so much money on
this maybe we won't ask as many
questions
is that was that your take on the
situation as well yes 100
i mean so what what happened was that
the fund when jolo went to a guy called
tim leisner who was a partner of goldman
in asia
who's now pleaded guilty to to helping
steal 200 million dollars
and this sentencing is is still to come
um
and they said look we need to we need to
raise all this money now did everyone at
goldman know that the money was going to
be
stolen no i don't think that that is the
case
but there were huge red flags at every
stage of the way
were missed um so goldman is saying this
guy tim leisner the former partner was a
rogue banker
okay that's their defense but i think
it's not as simple as that i think a lot
of people goldman
knew knew there were problems here for
example the fund in malaysia asked
they raised three billion dollar bond
and they asked for it to be put into a
swiss bank account
that the fund had now why would a
sovereign fund in malaysia have a swiss
bank account
and goldman's lawyers link laters
actually raised questions about this in
real time
it wasn't as if this is all hindsight
and they just said well you know this
bank's not on any
money laundering or terrorism black list
so let's just do it and everyone was
making huge huge bonuses
and so that was the problem you know
compliance we're telling
uh goldman's compliance was saying do
not deal with this guy jolo
they turned him down for a private bank
account it was pretty obvious because
you couldn't this guy had billions of
dollars but if you did a google search
he couldn't and he was claiming his
family money
um but if you did a google search you
couldn't find any mention of him
right and so the fact that all these
transactions went through is just
astounding
yeah and so when you say that they
raised these bonds
where did that money come from is this
institutions buying into the bonds is
this retail investors
where are the billions of dollars kind
of originally flowing from
yeah i mean like i said earlier this is
a post uh financial crisis
there's a lot there's obviously low
interest rates negative interest rates
a lot of liquidity and not that many
investments to make in the u.s and
and your stock market was down i mean
lloyd blankfein who was then
ceo of uh goldman is telling people you
know go out to asia
let's beat goldman in more places what's
the quote he he said at that time
which meant go and find in places to
invest and deals to do that aren't in
europe
and the us you know before they
recovered
um and so that's why investors were so
willing to snap up these uh these bonds
and they were they were very
they were very popular and they of
course they also yielded extremely high
high uh numbers because of the way they
said that goldman and the one mdb
structured it
yeah and so uh the funniest part to me
is
uh the way that you guys write the book
it seems like it's pretty obvious and
i'm sure there's some hindsight bias of
like hey here's all the red flags but
you know it would have taken somebody to
be intelligent and thoughtful and
thorough to put that together in real
time but it sounds like
kind of at each step of the way somebody
was raising red flags when you zoom out
and you look at
billions and billions of dollars uh the
part that sticks out is
just the arrogance of joe lowe and kind
of the other people involved
as to what they did with the money right
and so maybe talk a little bit about
like
as you guys are going to write the book
like how do you track down all the
assets and kind of
you know are you just kind of mind blown
every time you find more and more
ridiculous things that they use the
money for
yeah well the big thing the famous thing
that they used the money for was to buy
a film company called red granite
pitchers or to set up a film company
called red granite pitchers
which went on to make the wolf of wall
street with leonardo dicaprio and they
made daddy's home and dumb and dumber
too and a bunch of other films
so you're talking a little bit about how
do we uncover all of this well we
actually got hold of the email
server of red granite pitchers and in
there were all the
the the cell phone numbers of all the
hollywood stars
and we also then noticed that there were
lots of playboy playmates in there
uh sort of scores of them and so we just
set to
doing sort of traditional reporting
which is just calling the numbers and
asking to speak to people
so we spoke to we called like all the
playboy playmates these were the ones
who were in the magazine in 2009 2010
and we we finally got one a woman called
stephanie larimore who said oh yes i
remember
uh jolo and um yeah we partied with him
in leonardo dicaprio
in the palazzo in vegas in 2009
and she told this strange story of like
there being 20 plus playmates
dicaprio jolo and almost no one else um
playing baccarat and
partying and dancing and so that's the
chapter in the book called um
an evening with the playmates and that
was jolo's mo
right he'd stolen all his money he was
probably one of the most liquid cash
guys in the world because he didn't have
a real business he just had the money
and he wanted to go and make songs and
so he was courting dicaprio
telling him we will give you you know
hundreds of millions of dollars to make
your next four
films with scorsese they were going to
make the irishman before all this this
blew up
um and that was that was how he operated
and he would spend
money like nobody's business right i
mean you
that's the most amazing thing to me i
remember the one story where he i think
it was his birthday party maybe he was
throwing the birthday party for somebody
in an airport hangar
uh it's yeah it was actually a it's a
prologue of the book so for his
his 31st birthday he hired a vacant
locker lot off the strip and turned it
into sort of like an airport hangar
um and it was it was like the oscars i
mean the
you know the caliber of actors who were
there and
i mean people had heard about this guy
and and they didn't really know
i mean dicaprio was given lots of gifts
from joel of picasso paintings and that
kind of thing but there's no idea that
these guys knew that
he was for fraud um and they gave back
these gifts in the end
but i think if you're in hollywood
you're used to people with a lot of
money
uh coming by and financing your film and
you don't necessarily question
uh where they come from right and there
were all these rumors about joe all the
time is he an arms dealer
is he a friend of the prime minister but
i think it was there was a sort of
orientalism here you're able to say okay
this guy's just out in asia
yeah there's a lot of money in asia we
don't need to probe much more deeply
than that
but it's a massive embarrassment to all
the people who uh yeah everyone i mean
jamie foxx would emcee for him and take
you know do a lunchtime speech and take
millions um
swiss beats alicia keys husband was
hanging with him all the time and
getting paid
you know right up to the very end and
even after it was exposed
so it's just an amazing network of this
guy yeah
and i guess like what do those people
think about it now right i mean you
mentioned some pretty big well-known
people is it something where they
actually
are a little embarrassed and maybe like
uh you know i got duped a little bit
or was it something where they kind of
throw their hands up say look we had no
clue we never asked and uh
you know frank i don't care i just had a
good time and move on with my life
well you have to say you got duped
because if you didn't get duped you were
you were complicit right so
i mean everyone says they got duped or
they just didn't realize i mean there's
there's another scene in billion dollar
whale where jordan belford
who of course is the real wolf of wall
street is on set he's not on
so he's at this launch party the cam
film festival that they put on
to say look with his new film company
and we're going to make the wolf of wall
street
and he's in the crowd and he says you
know turns to his girlfriend and he goes
this is a [ __ ] scam
nobody would spend their own money like
this and what he means is like they've
spent they've spent
millions on this launch party and
they're not even they haven't even made
a film yet
so there were real people there were
people who in real time
uh saw it as a fraud right but you know
dicaprio says that he was he just didn't
know and that um you know when he found
out he gave the money back
and of course jolo went on to date
miranda kerr the australian supermodel
um and you know gave her jewelry worth
eight million dollars
and she also she she was with him for
about a year and she also says look i
didn't know
the true story about this guy um
i think people just you know they saw
her money bags and they didn't bother to
ask any questions that's all i can all i
can say about it
yeah i looked before uh before we did
this at some of the assets
uh that were reported as um you know
some of the the new information that
came out
and uh i was shocked so you get
multi-million dollar properties in
you know la new york london elsewhere
you've got about a 250 million dollar
yacht you've got a 35 million dollar
private jet you've got
obviously the see-through piano in
miranda kerr's house they like can't get
out of the house
um i mean it was like you know you're
kind of reading through this list and
you're like what would you do if you
never had money before and now all of a
sudden you're given billions of dollars
and you could go like
spend it on whatever you want like this
was literally like the christmas list
right
yeah the miranda curse perspex per spec
piano that they cannot get out of her
malibu home because they built walls
around it i love that story okay
so they so what we should say is in 2016
the the department of justice in the u.s
uh moved to seize all these assets right
so what happens in the if you
you obviously fraudsters from around the
world like to spend their money in the
u.s because you can get
bang for your buck you can buy a 100
million dollar apartment on central park
and that kind of thing
and they like living there as well um
and so jolo bought for example an
apartment in the
time warner center in columbus circle
which had been jay-z and beyonce's
apartment um he bought he bought a
mansion
on the bird streets uh in uh los angeles
which is close to where dicaprio lives
um they actually set up their offices on
the same building as dicaprio's
production company on the on the sunset
strip
so um yeah he he he they really moved
into the us in assets in a big way
because that was a way to
first of all he wanted to be a big
player in the us not just in hollywood
but also he was looking to buy
reebok from adidas he was looking to buy
tom ford the maker of james bond suits
and he bought the century he bought the
parklane hotel the big hotel in central
park south
um so he was he was setting himself up
he became a he became the asia
president of emi music publishing and he
and
was involved in that investment too so
he was he was really trying to become a
real investor and a real billionaire
you know even though the whole thing was
a sham yeah it's almost like
if i can steal some money to get started
then i
can go and try to become legitimate at
some you know former fashion
uh which is pretty crazy um obviously
the reason why i wanted to talk is
uh goldman just announced that there's a
new settlement and so
uh maybe give us a little back story in
terms of kind of what's happening with
the goldman bankers i think that's kind
of a unique situation
some of the prior offers and then where
ultimately this settlement is
is kind of netting out yeah so when this
whole thing came crashing down as i said
these stories started coming out in 2015
and then you know we spent between 2015
and 2018
writing many different stories and
writing the book goldman at the time was
saying look i mean we just did a
very beginning they said we were just
the banker we just did a
normal job raising money we had no idea
whether whether excuse me to drink
got a bit of a got a bit of a sniffle no
not copper don't worry
um uh
they said look we could not possibly
have known where that this was fraud we
just raised the money
okay but then it transpired the the main
banker on the deal tim leisner
a german national who was a partner and
a very senior guy who was actually ended
up becoming chairman of southeast asia
for goldman
he was he was in on the fraud and he has
admitted that to american investigators
now
um helped set up funds to move 200
million dollars around
including to um they even discussed
buying jewelry for the wife of
of najib razak the prime minister who
was this who when she was arrested in
malaysia
uh had 250 million dollars of loose
items in her apartment you know jewelry
and bags
birkin bags and all that kind of thing
um and so it became more and more
difficult for goldman said nothing had
happened and then they
then they said well look this was a
rogue banker um this guy and another guy
called roger allen who's also been
arrested he was a malaysian banker at
gordman
so they said look lloyd blankfein wasn't
involved gary cohen who was a big
who was the number two at goldman at the
time he went on to be trump's economic
advice these guys weren't involved
but then malaysia in 2008 2018 they
actually
um uh filed criminal charges against a
number
of goldman bankers uh senior executives
so what happened uh just the last few
days is goldman has had to settle with
them with malaysia to get those charges
dropped
and it's agreed to pay 2.5 billion
dollars to malaysia
um now this is not including the
settlement they're gonna have to do with
the doj
the department of justice in the u.s it
doesn't include any criminal this is
just a civil case it doesn't include any
criminal matters in in the u.s um and
that is
five times the amount that goldman paid
in fines
after the the global factual crisis they
paid 500 million for the whole subprime
you remember abacus all of that stuff
only 500 only 500 million but like a
fifth and this is only just starting so
i don't think people quite realize how
i mean the book's done well right we saw
quite a few copies of it and and people
people like yourself know the story but
i think people don't realize the size of
this fraud
and the implications of it and when i
think you know we're hearing
it could be as early as next week that
uh goldman settle in the u.s
and that's there's going to be even sort
of higher higher uh
fines and so this is also this is all
still to play out we don't know what the
and then the big question is will
goldman have to plead guilty which of
course
that never really happened after the
global financial crisis are all these
deferred prosecution agreements
where you you paid a fine but you didn't
plead guilty so
that's all to play out yeah and so um
the 2.5 billion dollar settlement is in
cash
and then the number that everyone keeps
seeing is 3.9 billion and obviously that
1.4
billion difference isn't in cash
describe a little bit
kind of this whole idea of like
guaranteeing assets and
why is the media reporting a 3.9 billion
dollar settlement with malaysia but only
2.5 billions in cash
well the malaysian government was under
a huge pressure to come up with a huge
number
because they've got a show they're there
um and
what's gold goldman is doing is paying
2.5 in cash and then it's then there's
1.4 billion of assets these assets that
the us has seized which includes you
know
jolo's apartment that in in columbus
circle in the time warner building those
kind of things the the initial
lawsuits in the u.s were u.s versus wolf
of wall street they actually seized the
film the the prophets from the film
so what goldman's saying is we will
guarantee that you get back from the us
government
1.4 billion um it's been described as a
sort of a put like almost a put right
um but i don't think um goldman would
have done that if it
if it hadn't looked at the assets and
worked out what they're worth and
realized that it's not not a huge risk
right goldman doesn't do that kind of
thing
without getting its analysts to really
look closely so that's not really a co i
don't really see that as a cost to
goldman i mean i could be wrong maybe
the assets will come in at only
700 you know you know or 70
of what that 1.4 billion right
um but i just think it's unlikely i mean
it's just that it's just a sort of a
financial engineering thing i think
yeah and so in exchange for this kind of
2.5 billion dollars in cash and then the
guarantee on the assets uh
it sounds like malaysia has agreed to
basically drop all charges criminally
against goldman
as an organization um and pretty much
everyone except for
the two you know quote-unquote rogue
bankers or is that
incorrect no that's that's totally
correct so the so that so then these two
road bankers well i mean i'm not calling
them rogue bankers because i actually
think they were
there were more people that knew about
it that were that were um
at least turning a blind eye um but yeah
these two bankers
um tim leisner and roger ang they have
got criminal cases on going against them
in in the us and as i said
roger ung has said it has pleaded not
guilty but tim leisner has pleaded
guilty and he's been cooperating
um and so his sentencing should i mean
it's been just postponed a number of
times since last summer
but everyone's waiting to see what
happens there because um
i don't i mean i can't imagine his
corporation was that useful because it's
not as if they've rounded up and charged
a bunch of other goldman bankers right
so you know like goldman's uh argument
that this was a rogue is i guess partly
true but but the point is
there were a lot of other people that
knew there were red flags because you
know in the emails
that we've seen for example they they
all talk about oh we must keep jolo
out of this you know we'll do business
with him but we can't be seen to be
doing business with him so
i think i think the knowledge of the
shadiness of this practice went much
deeper a goal than just those two
bankers
yeah and my understanding from uh kind
of reading some of the news reports
after i read the book was
um i think it's tim weisner has given
back like
40 million dollars and kind of there's a
bunch of money that's moving around and
frankly
when you're talking about billions of
dollars in a fraud
any number smaller than a billion kind
of seems small right but
for an individual to kind of turn over
40 million dollars one like that's what
supposedly or he's allegedly earned from
doing these deals
uh so that's personal income like pretty
big number and then to actually turn
around
and give it back as part of these you
know pleading guilty whatever
what is interesting though you mentioned
the 500 million dollars that goldman
paid during the global financial crisis
and now you've got 2.5 billion here
but the global financial crisis also i
don't know definitely nobody at goldman
that i know of was arrested i don't
think
kind of anyone really across wall street
was really arrested uh on the criminal
side and so
kind of how do you see that playing out
in the u.s so you've got two guys who've
played
uh one guy's played guilty one who's
played not guilty
but this feels very different and feels
like actually there are going to be some
people who get in trouble here
well i think this is i mean i'm guessing
or i'm hoping at least this is when it
really
is going to get into the it's going to
go wider in the u.s and more people will
be aware of it as a story not just you
know financial types or people like
reading business books or
you know i mean the hollywood angles
already let it jump
over a little bit to that that audience
but um
and i think when a goldman banker a
partner
is sentenced to jail if if that happens
which i can't see
like i mean i would be surprised if
there was any other outcome that's going
to that's going to generate a lot of
headlines because
like you said after the financial crisis
nobody did but i think there was one
banker from credit suisse who went to
jail and i think that was it
um it really wasn't there really wasn't
very much you remember fabulous fab
uh who was the goldman banker who was he
talked about selling products to widows
and
orphans and all of that but but there
wasn't really very much criminal
sanction
um after the global financial crisis as
we as we just said there's there were a
lot of deferred prosecution agreements
where you pay a fine and you you don't
admit guilt
um so the big thing that goldman
goldman's lawyers now
um kirtland and ellis um which is built
by
attorney general bill barzold firm are
um
uh negotiating very very hard with the
department of justice to not plead
guilty
and the wall street journal had a story
earlier this year that they that they
had
agreed in principle to plead guilty at
the singapore
unit level which is which fits their
rogue narrative
uh narrative their rogue banker
narrative right which is it all happened
under tim leicester in the singapore
office
um whereas i think a lot of people at
doj
want to have goldman plead guilty at the
firm level
so that's that's a really important
thing to watch
what is the difference there right
obviously it's kind of the whole company
versus a single office but kind of what
are the ramifications of if the guilty
plea came in at the firm level versus
the single office
well lord blankfein was the chief
executive during all of this he he was
the chief executive during the subprime
meltdown he was a chief executive during
the whole libyan debacle which you might
know about
um and then he was the chief executive
for this he left in the fall of 2018
and so the question is did he did he
retire was he pushed out his
his options have actually been uh
suspended uh some of his payers being
suspended
were at pending the end of this
investigation um
so it's a huge question whether it's
firm wide or whether it's
uh it's only at the singapore unit
because if it's firm wide
then then the very top dogs at the bank
have to admit
uh their role in it or that they failed
in their oversight
um lloyd blankfein met joe lowe at least
on two occasions i believe
um in in new york in goldman's
headquarters in one on one occasion
um you don't get to see lloyd blankfein
unless you you know you're vetted
and i think he met him with nadjib at
one point now goldman would
would say look he was uh
you know he was seen as an emissary of
um najib najib was the prime minister
how could we have known
but you know don't forget at that time
goldman's compliance department was
saying don't open a private bank account
for this chill guy
right goldman are very smart you know
they know they they knew who jolo was i
i can't believe they could say well you
know blank friend met him and didn't
know who he was
um and and there were all these
questions about you know don't do deals
with them and even after one mdp even
after this whole fraud
collapsed um there were there were
goldman bankers in the middle east
a guy called hassan schalke who
continued to do deals with jolo
um with compliance telling him look
you've got to keep joelo you can't
you can't you can't do the deal directly
with joe lojello has to be on the other
side and they did they did these
these investment deals it's a very
complicated story but the point is
you know they knew jolo was there they
knew they had questions about jolo but
they did all this business anyway
because the fees were just so
so so high right yeah capitalism drives
a uh
drives a very specific type of uh
activity um what do you think happens in
the us
right so there's the guilty plea or not
guilty plea kind of wherever that comes
out
but from a fine perspective are you
expecting something that's going to be
bigger than the 2.5 billion dollar
settlement with uh the malaysian
government
smaller kind of just talk me through you
know what your expectations i guess are
right now
well i actually went on squawk box um
with andrew ross sulkin
maybe a couple of years back now or 18
months ago and i said he asked me what
fine do you think
they would do and i said that they would
put on goldman
and i said the us would put a fine of
two billion and
very senior goldman executives phoned up
the wall street journal and complained
at that time right that this was like
you know
and and the yardstick then was well jp
morgan had been fined
2 billion for bernie madoff's accounts
which they had failed to
to signal red flags right this is all
done under the bank secrecy act
it's not it's not a criminal matter this
is you know you're fined for
failing to uh see red flags and act upon
them and tell authorities
and so if it's anywhere in the in the
sort of uh
jpmorgan range it could be another two
billion and that could be four up to
five billion
but the question is does the malaysian
how does the malaysian fine
relate to the us fine is is there some
sort of like overall number that goldman
has organized and they have to give it
to malaysia not the us
i mean i don't i'm not quite sure on
that so we'll have to just wait and see
yeah and then the criminal matter is a
separate thing that's just that's
rolling through the courts right
yeah it's very interesting to me um i
read the book
black edge which about steve cohen and
sac capital uh this situation is
similar in that um you know there's
almost this like weird negotiation i
think the kind of the average person
hears oh there's law enforcement
involved that you know whether it's the
federal level or whatever
hey they're just gonna say you're in
trouble you know here's your charges go
to court
and uh and basically you get whatever uh
judgment you get
right but here there is very much this
negotiation like you talked about what
lawyers are going in and
kind of they have the here's what we're
willing to do here's what we're not
willing to do here's how much we're
willing to pay
and then the negotiation starts and so
it almost feels like
kind of the richer the more powerful you
are
the more leverage you have in these
scenarios because it's goldman sachs on
the other side from the doj
not you know you me or any other
individual
yeah and like i mentioned it's a
revolving door problem i mean goldman's
lawyers of kirkland and ellis bill
barley a g
who used to work there i mean there's no
he
i'm not sure he's recused himself on uh
on it i'm not i i think you've got to
waive it
um so that so um the question is
why has there not already been a
settlement this
this these stories started coming out
2015 the
civil uh department of justice attempts
to take the assets started in 2016.
we're now in 2020 so i might have huge
questions about i mean our book came out
almost two years ago um i think the
broad controls of this
have been known for for a while right
and so why
why has there not been a settlement so
far well yeah exactly there's a
there are very powerful lawyers that
have to negotiate with the department of
justice to
to um to try to work out what goldman's
willing to pay
and willing to do um and that's a
fascinating process to watch
um and of course goldman says as i
mentioned they say look we didn't know
they this is the line they'll be pushing
very hard we just didn't know that
you know lloyd blankfein did not know
that tim lyson of the partner was
was dealing corruptly with joe lowe and
i think that's probably right actually
but it's but it's
on on every other level it you know is
it true that goldman didn't know that
there were red flags here
i mean well demonstrably not because
they're their own compliance department
you know knew that there was problems
opening an account for him so
so that so yeah the goldman sachs
government is obviously an extremely
powerful institution and is able to
has been able to sort of stretch this
out
over a long period of time yeah it's
obviously a very very complex situation
um i want to talk a little bit about
your process in writing the book so i
asked people for questions beforehand
and a couple of people
you know some variation of just uh
you're dealing with a lot of money
very fraudulent complex situation very
powerful people
or people who are very egotistical what
were some of the things that people did
to stop you from either getting
information
getting access to people or really kind
of being able to complete the body of
work
well at one point i was in malaysia
reporting in um
in in a hotel in malaysia
and bradley hope who's the co-author of
the book my great friend
he was called up by one of our sources
who was close to the malaysian prime
minister and told look um
the malaysian prime minister is trying
he's thinking of arresting tom in
malaysia and he should really get out of
the country
and it was framed as a as a sort of
friendly
advice but actually it was this person
we later found out was you know
in cahoots with the prime minister and
so things like that just trying to
stop us uh reporting on the ground um
a lot of legal threats crazy number of
legal threats you know so for example
we'd we'd write to
um i don't know christie's for example
who
did a lot of jolo became one of the
biggest buyers of art in the world
um and they would immediately write a
bunch of questions from
what we were going to say in the book
which was very sort of you know fact
based and they'd write back
with a very very aggressive letter um
same with uh teperberg and strauss who
are these two guys who run the marquee
nightclub in new york and
lavo in in vegas in a very aggressive
legal letter back when you said to them
look
uh we're gonna say that you were you
organized all of jolo's parties over a
long multi-year period and
were paid you know a lot of money to do
so um and so you
you know it was very stressful at that
time because we were fact checking you
know in the book it's just almost 400
page book and
there's an allegation on almost every
page and so we we we checked with
every single person i think at one point
you know the prologue of the book is
this big party we mentioned
on in the you men you you called it an
aircraft hangar it almost looked like an
aircraft hangar
we talked to every single person who was
supposed to be there so at one point i
think we called up jonah hill's agent
and said
you know it was jonah hill there and
they said oh actually he was supposed to
go but he was on the guest list we had
but he didn't turn up so you know it was
super fact checked
um and people did people would just they
would do anything to try to stop
the book and then sorry the elephant in
the room is jolo's lawyers
shillings um they sent letters to all
the bookshops
that were going to carry this book
around the world saying if you stock
this you could be liable to a defamation
suit
which was nonsense because why would a
bookshop i mean it's the writer of the
book that should give a definition to
but it was all it was all just
a tactic to scare people not to have the
book and it was
it was it's what's called the streisand
effect which is when barbara streisand
tried to stop people posting her photos
and everyone ended up looking at them
right
the book just got like much more
attention because of all that so no none
of it were but
the truth comes out eventually it's
literally like the perfect book to write
right you've got financial fraud
billions of dollars a bunch of famous
people very powerful people i mean just
literally you know it kind of sells
itself to some degree um
were you ever able to talk to joe lowe's
attorneys or to joe lowe himself
um yeah we we definitely talked to his
attorneys and sent lots of questions to
him via them but they they have not they
have not engaged schillings
um and cobra and kim who his lawyers in
the u.s did not engage with us in any
way over a multi-year period i mean they
would engage with us but just with pro
forma
letters saying that we you know we're
not doing we're not allowing his side
out but they never answered any uh he
or jolo via his lawyers has not until
today answered any substantive questions
um and we should talk about where jolo
is by the way so one of my questions is
going to be where
where do you think he is well i mean
well we knew he was in china at one
point so so we should say the the
lawsuits that civil law suits 2016 in
the us
and then in 2018 the u.s and malaysia
both filed criminal charges against
jhola
and at the same time the prime minister
of malaysia najib razak loses power in
an election in malaysia and he's
he's arrested um and i think his najib's
verdict by the way might come out
today um in asia or or tomorrow or
something like that
so um jolo is told by the prime minister
to get out of the country
and he goes to china um and this is this
is where the story gets very complicated
but it's just unbelievably
interesting he's able to do deals so
najib at that point is still
uh prime minister is before he loses
power in the elections and he's able to
do these infrastructure deals
with china and malaysia and they steal
even more money this is not the one mdb
floor this is just
post 1mdb to use to to fill some of the
holes
and he uses the a friend in kuwait who's
the former prime minister's son
excuse me um and he's able to he's able
to sort of
keep doing deals and uh china has not um
said anything about it but we got
minutes of a meeting we know that jolo's
protector in china at one point was a
guy called sun lee jun
who was a head of the domestic security
forces
that guy has just been um arrested for
corruption in china
um without any comment by the by xi
jinping's government so
what we we believe there's sort of a
clearing of house going on in china
about this but jolo is still there
and of course he's a very useful pawn
for anyone who who holds him
right because you know he knows all this
stuff um
about where the money's gone he still
controls a lot of money too
and he's still paying his lawyers um
which we don't understand how he can do
but he's still paying his lawyers in the
u.s
millions of dollars so so uh any idea
where he is in china or just
kind of the the general idea is just in
china somewhere
well this isn't a joke he was definitely
in wuhan at one point we have we have
sort of
intelligence it was in wuhan um this is
before the um
the virus started um since then to be
honest
that would be very early this year or
actually late last year since then i
don't know exactly where he is but um
i i'm not sure whether he can travel
it's possible he can travel or until
recently he's been able to travel into
the middle east
the uae to because a lot of people are
trying to cover this up right for
example
um the uae was involved involved in this
the
shake man saw the owner of man city uh
uh football club soccer club in the us
in england um he his boat the 650
million dollar topaz
which is now called the a plus was
partly financed with money from
stolen from one mbb so there's no
there's a lot of people who don't really
want this
you know uh to be raked over and so he's
possible joel
can travel to those countries too on
private jets but i imagine the chinese
authorities are keeping him pretty
much in their sights right um because
they want to control him
yeah absolutely and it's the thought
process when you say he's got control
over money is that something that
it's just nobody really understands but
he's obviously paying some of these
bills that we know are expensive
or is it something where um we think
he's literally walking around with
duffel bags of cash or
kind of how do you think that somebody
who uh is really this like international
uh wanted man still has control over
money and can kind of do some things
well he moved money into chinese yuan
for sure because when he was trying to
pay off some of these
corrupt deals i just mentioned they were
moving it around by icbc which is a
chinese bank in yuan
and the reason to do that is to avoid uh
if you do a dollar transaction you could
end up
getting caught by the corresponding bank
right it has to be
it has to be checked and so he's
basically been frozen out of the u.s
system
but he's i think he's still got access
to thai baht or
chinese yuan and all of all these
currencies he tried to buy a bank in
i think the komoros islands at one point
uh post all this coming out right so he
could control money
and obviously china's becoming a bigger
bigger player in the global economy and
so
you can do stuff with iwan and it's and
it's not you know it's it's
to a degree a bit more internationalized
than it used to be even though they
still have a closed capital
capital account right um so that's
that's i think how he's operating
um but it's incredible to me that the
big question i have is cobra uh
cobra and kim right his lawyers are
they're a big law firm
shillings in the uk they're getting paid
money um they
cobra and kim uh had to file a form a
pharaoh form which is
to show to the us government that
they're lobbying for him and they're not
they're not obviously paid by him
they paid they were paid by a thai guy a
thai friend of jolos
but i don't understand how you can say
well you know
we know that this money is not the
proceeds of crime you know lawyers
everyone's everyone's allowed a lawyer
right that's uh and jolo has not been
proven guilty you know he's only he's
only been he hasn't
turned up to face the charges but he
hasn't been proven guilty so that's fair
he needs a lawyer
but but for so when it comes to um
taking
lawyers taking money to do lobbying to
send letters to try to stop a book being
published like a billion dollar whale
i mean then i have questions about well
how do you how are those lawyers proving
that the
the money was not tainted um extremely
extremely
interesting situation yeah the part to
me that i think just blows my mind is
you've got a guy who
uh it almost seems in some weird way uh
has a very tainted reputation but has
become emboldened
after the scam was uh uncovered
like you almost get like one of these
weird things where you could imagine
this guy is like bragging about the fact
that there's a book written about him
and he just forgets the part of like
that it's written about a scam right
like it's almost like the fame and the
the egotistical nature of all of this
is driving him to do more and more to
some degree it sounds like for some of
these stories
well as well his favorite book um we
learned was
uh the book about mark rich so mark mark
rich was the oil trader
who ended up getting um charged in the
u.s and he lived his life out in
switzerland on the shores of lake
lugano in a luxurious villa and and i
think jolo sort of saw this guy as his
model in a way
and and rich was pardoned by bill
clinton on his last day in office
um and so i think jolo really saw that
as his end game to get a sort of a
pardon
um and as i said the story is super
complicated but
making it even more complicated the the
party of najib
the former prime minister who's been
um is is now coming back to power in
malaysia and so there's this idea that
maybe all the charges will get dropped
in malaysia
if that party solidifies its grip on
power and then jolo might be able
might actually be able to come back to
the country i mean it's not i'm not not
unbelievable
i mean it's a very very corrupt place is
his family still in malaysia
no they're all on the run with him i
mean i think his dad has been charged by
the malaysian government
um so there was a change of power in
later in the new government pushed ahead
with all these charges
but then that government is now out of
power again and so
you know it's a it's a fluid situation
yeah absolutely
um in terms of writing the book uh were
there any kind of really crazy stories
that didn't make it into the book or
things that you guys wanted to write
about but you you just couldn't get
confirmation or
or anything like that um there was one
thing we didn't put in which
subsequently the um i think the new york
posters reported which was kim
kardashian was given a
white uh and chris what was her husband
called chris hudson chris
her former husband humphreys humphreys
but the
the two of them had been given by jolo
at a wedding a white
ferrari and then of course they got
divorced a few days later
and all the wedding guests were
complaining that their gifts had not
been returned but there was a
i mentioned in a legal uh filing i think
by chris humphries that
but you know i haven't got my fair share
of the wedding gifts including a white
ferrari from a
malaysian businessman and i think the
new the new york
post has confirmed that was jolo um and
so that that i don't know where that
white ferrari is i have a i have a
an interest in finding out whether that
was ever given back to the us government
or not or whether kim kardashian still
has that
i mean the story is every single time
you hear one of these right it's just
like
so crazy how entrenched he was into u.s
politics
culture uh kind of business i mean he
literally was able to influence
everything well we haven't even well we
haven't even talked about how we tried
to infiltrate the white house we tried
to do
with obama the same thing he had done
with you know the malaysian prime
minister
the the powers of being the middle east
he actually met obama
at once um he got close to a guy that
was there was an obama fundraiser
um he was a sort of distant relation of
michelle obama
and he he that guy was a businessman and
he did all these sort of weird business
deals that made that guy
a bunch of money um but of course it's
not as easy to infiltrate the white
house as it is
to to do that with malaysia and uh and
the middle east and so he wasn't he
wasn't really all that successful in
getting that close to obama but he did
he did via press michelle who i don't
you know who pressed michelle is
i do not yeah this is this is a
generational thing
michelle was the the rapper from the
fuji's you know the lauren hill
group and surprise michelle who
literally opens our book
became a really good friend of jolos um
and he
he illegally well allegedly illegally
contributed
to the obama re-election campaign
because of course foreigners are not
allowed to
uh uh contribute into u.s politics but
jolo used press michelle as a storeman
allegedly to pay uh to put money into a
super pack for obama's re-elections that
was all part of his attempts to get
closer to the white house
and press michelle is facing a bunch of
problems because
when all this came out joel also tried
to get the department of justice to drop
all these
investigations into one mdv and he he
actually offered press michelle 300
million dollars if they were able to
pass myself at a friend of the
department of justice and they were
working to
try to influence the investigations in
some way and then and
yeah all of that stuff was all that
stuff didn't work out either so
fascinating yeah it's one of these
things where uh when people have money
to just throw around 300 million dollars
is crazy and
uh i think there's a story at one point
they're in um
somewhere in europe maybe and maybe a
visa or something and they're like at a
club
and he's basically just spending you
know a million two million bucks at the
club
on a single night you're just like look
you know you start doing the math that's
a lot of bottles or that's you know a
lot of really expensive bottles of
alcohol
to spend two million dollars in this and
a club in a single night
well yeah that was you're referring to
uh he got into a
bat a champagne battle with winston
fisher who's a a new york real estate
family
and they would they were bidding each
other in in the carved which is a
famous uh nightclub in it's actually in
um
sancho bay not ibiza um and uh
yeah they he they sort of bit each other
up to some crazy number i think it was
two million euro in the end
it was it was he would go into a club
and just say uh crystal for everybody
you know and so people quite enjoyed
hanging with that and there's
a there's another sort of famous scene
in the book where they do a double
dateline
uh new year's eve they go to sydney and
then they go to
uh las vegas and you know jamie foxx is
in the plane and
swizz beats is in the plane and there's
all these photos on instagram you know
of them
just have buckets of cristal everywhere
yeah
i think people are kind of sick of this
[Laughter]
absolutely insane um talk to me a little
bit just about
uh you wrote this book went super deep
on on this specific fraud and kind of
really unpacked like how a fraud comes
together how uh
it gets enabled and kind of what the
money you know what
people do with the money how do you
think about this getting repeated in the
future right whether it's now during
kind of covid in the economic recession
um or maybe at some other time like are
you looking for
kind of the next you know 1mdb type
scandal
um or do you kind of just wait for them
to come to you
it's 100 gonna happen again i mean you
know there's there's a
there's a case that's also rolling on
right now very similar involving credit
swiss
and mozambique where they they bought a
bunch of tuna fishing boats the
government bought some fishing boats
and they took out a two billion dollar
loan
with via credit first and some other
banks and a couple of credit swiss
bankers would be charged i think for
it is very similar thing you know huge
loans from the market
a country without rule of law on one
side um
and that that's you know that's a big
problem i mean look i talked to my
goldman
uh friends and they say you can't get
it's hard to get deals through now
because you've got to go through
extra stringent procedures at the
capital commitments committee and all of
this
um and there are good people at goldman
of course it's not like full of people
like tim lanza
and does banking fulfill a function in
our world yeah it does
but i think at the margins there's
always going to be people
who want to make big bonuses and are
under pressure to make big
their big uh you know deals and you know
they're not that easy to come by
that's the big secret in banking right
it's just not that easy especially if
you're in a
fairly small market like southeast asia
like tim leisner was you want to make
partner you ought to do a big deal
and how do you you know if you're doing
deals in china right now with chinese
companies how do you know
sometimes you don't even know who owns a
chinese company might claim to be
private maybe the government's behind it
and so it's very hard to do the kind of
due diligence you need to do to stop
these thoughts happening
and um you could argue that just part of
the way you know
capitalism works you nee it'll happen
and but you need
you need open markets you need you need
this for the for
the way our world works but you need to
also have
regulators who crack down on it i think
that's the key
yeah and it feels in some weird way you
know you see the kind of luck in coffees
in china that come out
and you know i think the consensus in
the market is that it was some
sort of fraud or scam or whatever and
there's almost like two categories right
there's the like oh that they were just
lying about their numbers and
so there was financial engineering going
on or there's like this which is
hey they fraudulently got access to
billions of dollars and then they went
and they spent it on ferraris and
you know yachts and jets and kind of all
the crazy
cliterati type lifestyle and to your
point i think that the
the more traditional like corporate
fraud of just hey i said i have x number
in revenue but i didn't
uh almost has been we've been
desensitized to some degree to that
it's this type of stuff now where people
are you know they're still blown away
when they see somebody got hold of six
or seven billion dollars in cash and
then went and literally blew it across
the world
uh you know with the rich and famous in
the world well i mean i i mean yes i
think you made a great point i mean i
listened to the we crashed podcast about
wework right and i'm like well
that's no one's saying adam newman did
anything fraudulent
okay but we have become desensitized
because you know how were the
stewards of that company allowing that
kind of spending to go on right
um and i think that's probably how jolo
in his own mind would justify his
actions he'd say look i'm
i was just doing what you know the
jordan belfords of the world did
and you know this is just how this is
how smart people make the most of this
system
right um and you know we didn't want to
make the book too preachy or anything
but i think there's a couple of moments
where
we try to say look i mean if we want the
system and it's all tied up with
everything that's going on right now
inequality
and people's sense of like i'm working
on a on a you know six dollar an hour
job or whatever it is
and they're sick of that and they see
all this um
if you don't if you don't like make it
more equitable then the system's just
not gonna work in the long run
so and one of the last questions i have
before we get into some rapid fire
questions to finish up it's just
he made he financed the wolf of wall
street
and so there's some irony in a fraud
financing
a movie about one of the most famous
american frauds in history
what was your take on that and kind of
was that more of a
i've got to tell this and this is like a
bat signal to the world that i'm a fraud
or was it just coincidence how did you
guys kind of look at that
well i think it's like it follows on
from what we were just saying i don't
think jolo is
is that smart or into literature to
think that it was so meta and that he
had to do such a meta move i don't think
that was what was going on but i think
he was attracted by the the people like
jordan belfort
um and he was attracted by dicaprio
you know who had played jay gatsby you
know in the
in in baslerman's film of the great
gatsby and so this was this was a very
meta situation where
jolo was was meeting jordan belford and
and dicaprio was a character actor was
meeting joelo i mean dicaprio says he
didn't know he was of the fraud at the
time
um but i don't know i don't think he had
any sort of great
um intellectual idea that this was such
a meta move i just think he was
attracted to those kind of
people because he and he sort of sort of
a valid you know you're a loser in
capitalism if you don't
make these kind of you know badass moves
probably something just like that
absolutely insane i asked two questions
to uh to wrap it up and you could ask me
one uh as the last one but
uh what is the most important book that
you've ever read
oh most important well one of my
favorite books is a sheltering sky
um which is which is a
actually i've got it here on my
bookshelf i think but it's by like it's
a guy called paul balls
and it's a fantastic fantastic novel um
said in sub-saharan africa
that's that's that's what that's my
favorite sort of fiction in terms of
uh important book of nonfiction um
well i've just read rudger bregman's
book about happiness
um which is uh should i just step up and
pick it up very quickly
sure go ahead hang on
for those that are uh are listening uh
tom is literally going to the bookcase
behind him right now
and uh and grabbing the book which is uh
makes him an expert because he knows
exactly where the book is
well i just read it so so this this book
uh humankind
by a very smart young dutch thinker
is it's trying to it's it's sort of like
um
it goes against the grain of the jared
diamonds you know and the
the stephen pinkers and this idea well
actually maybe some more jared diamond
this idea that you know humans are bad
and that and that um you know we have a
deep core of badness
and he's trying to say look we have we
we actually are
deep down um good people and and
he spins it into a fantastic fantastic
book and um
he starts off by talking about the
famous lord of the flies uh william
golding's book
and he finds a real life example of boys
who were marooned in the pacific and
they did not
end up almost killing each other they
cooperated and they kept the fire going
and all of that i just found this so
i found that a fantastic book really
really great read and the author's name
is rutger bregman
rutger bregman he's the guy you might
remember him he went to t he went to
he's the guy went to davos and to
all the ted talks um and uh
sort of he talked about basic income and
all that kind of stuff and he's sort of
like the anti-davos guy
very very smart very very well written
brilliantly written book yeah
i love that uh the second question is a
little bit more fun which is
aliens believer or non-believer
non-believer wow why a non-believer
just a rationalist atheist um
you know what i haven't even given it
much thought i don't i've never been
that pulled to
you know stargazing and thinking about
what's out there i i think you know
like i'm always amazed when i read
history that but like i just think most
of it's probably made up when you look
back at like people talk about herodotus
or something we
we can't i couldn't to even know what
happened between 2009 and 2015 with this
one mpv fraud was difficult enough right
and getting multiple sources on on
things so i find like um
you know whether aliens exist or not is
so far beyond you know
my comprehension i yeah i wouldn't even
go there
i recently tweeted saying that one of
the greatest lies we tell ourselves
uh lies in our memory right just our
personal memories are so
bad yet we have a hard time admitting
that to ourselves
as if your memory is bad imagine how
poorly history's written right from an
accuracy standpoint
exactly exactly that's why i like
dealing in narrative non-fiction because
it's not opinion you just find out what
happened and you
know you don't you try to give as little
opinion as possible um
i don't know how all these columnists uh
you know and also there's so much
opinion right now if you go on twitter
or
so much posturing and so little actual
reporting amongst amongst some of the
younger journalists i hate to say but
yeah i feel like you just need to get
facts because that's the only way to
to go forward absolutely uh you get to
ask me one question to finish up what's
the
one question you have yeah so i've
noticed that
there's amongst people who are into into
bitcoin this book is very popular
because they they keep making the
argument well this huge fraud
shows that uh you know fiat currencies
are
not the way to go when it comes to
starting fraud but i don't i'm not sure
i buy that either i feel like bitcoin is
is also going to be a great enabler of
fraud so what do you think about that
yeah so well so there's two pieces to
that so uh i've definitely seen a lot of
people who who say that
um i think that there's kind of two
parts to the fraud which is
could something uh disincentivize or
prevent the fraud from occurring
and then is there something on the back
and once the fraud has happened would it
be better for it that happened in fiat
or in
uh cryptocurrency or bitcoin or whatever
it is um i i definitely am with you that
i don't think that
bitcoin or fiat or really any currency
in the world would necessarily uh
prevent this from happening right money
is money and
bad people are gonna figure out bad
things to do and so there's bad people
who use bitcoin for things there's bad
people who use us dollars and every
other currency in the world so
i kind of don't buy that argument i
think what uh the argument that
i see um i see the uh validity of
yet i don't think necessarily uh people
have kind of thought through the the
second and third order effects of is oh
if bitcoin had been used you then
could because it is a public ledger
basically track down
the funds easier technically yes or kind
of from an academic
standpoint but as we've discussed if you
take the
currency again whatever currency it is
and you turn it into assets
it kind of you get back to square one
right so like if i take it
you know whether it's us dollars or
bitcoin i turn it into a 35 million
dollar jet you still got to go find the
jet
right and so i think that yes if it was
all sitting in cash you could track it
down or at least kind of get a better
picture if it was in bitcoin versus fiat
um but but once it's in assets i think
you know it kind of doesn't really
matter
um in terms of like just bitcoin on a
grander scheme
to me it really comes down to uh you're
either going to have
government-controlled currencies or
you're going to have separation of state
and money
right and i always tell people it's like
the separation of state money is
probably
uh low probability but
it's possible right so you kind of have
you have possibility but
low probability and uh if it does occur
it will be massive value creation right
because it's kind of one of these you
know
very small chance of happening but if it
happens it will be so outrageous in
terms of value creation
and i think that's also kind of pulls
certain types of people
into it where they say you know i want
the one in
a million chance of getting rich right
or whatever
and so i try to spend a lot of time
talking people back into reality a
little bit and like hey you know
put one percent of your assets there and
like you're good and
if it happens it happens great but like
don't go put 99 of all of your money in
bitcoin and cross your fingers and hope
you know it turns into
um kind of a trillion dollar asset but
uh there's i mean literally there's
people who tweeted me all the time and
they're like hey you know
somebody tweeted me yesterday it was
like 94 of my wealth is in bitcoin and
ether
and all i could think of myself was like
jesus that is not a smart move
so i don't know free free financial
advice all right good yeah
yeah yeah exactly like you know i uh i
joke with my partners all the time like
i never thought that as an investor i
would spend time telling people like put
less money in
right because most investors are always
saying hey you know you can do more you
can do more
but with this one asset it's just so
volatile and i think it
definitely attracts kind of a certain
personality type that you literally have
to talk people kind of off the edge be
like hey just chill out you'll be all
right like
cash is not you know horrible you can
hold some cash you'll be you'll be good
um so i think it's funny where uh where
can people find the uh the book
if they want to uh go buy it i know
there's an audio book and then also uh
yeah it's everywhere it's everywhere
amazon barnes noble um it's in all the
book stores
um and we should say um we're making a
film out of it uh the
the film company that made crazy rich
asians if you saw that film
uh in 2018 they've bought the rights to
it and so they're turning it into a
problem tv series um so that's some
progress yeah
very exciting absolutely and you know
for everyone who's listening
uh i almost never give book
recommendations but this is one that i
highly suggest
uh going to read because it's uh one i
read it very quickly but also too as you
walk away with this rare combination i
think of kind of the entertainment
factor of a lot of stuff we talked about
here but you also learn
you know just how does the global
financial system really work
especially in areas where you've got u.s
based
financial organizations operating in
other countries or other regions
and you just kind of get a different
picture of the world and uh you know tom
is
based in asia and so i'm assuming that
you know that definitely helps you right
from kind of a non-western perspective
which is a pretty compelling as well
yeah that's yeah that's right it's uh we
had a rule that we would have only one
that one page of money flow
before you get back to something else
because otherwise people don't read
people
corruption is important but people don't
care to read about corruption right so
yeah it's not a it's not a book about
corruption it's not a book about money
trail
there is some money trail in there but
you can always just skip over that if
you
they just want to know about the parties
and uh and the yachts and the jets man
that's all in the way and i i mean and
the way the world really works right
absolutely all right tom listen thank
you so much for doing this i i think
with the recent news with the goldman uh
settlement people are
super interested to kind of hear from
you so uh as we learn more we'll
do it again in the future thanks dude i
enjoyed it